alors Potain de stars les lunettes du
tueur en série Jeffrey dhammer si vous
ne connaissez pas c'est la série ganja
200 millions de vues sur Netflix c'est
un homme qui entre 78 à 91 a tué des
petits et brûlés 16 homosexuels c'était
un fou il y a pas d'autres mots et
aujourd'hui et bien c'est un tel
événement que tout ce qui portait les
lunettes les t-shirts et tout ça ça
devient des goodies ça se vend dans le
monde entier évidemment toutes les
familles de victimes crient au scandale
regardez
c'est l'événement Netflix de cette
rentrée
la série en 10 épisodes Dammer monstre
l'histoire de Jeffrey Dahmer une affaire
qui a bouleversé toute l'Amérique dans
les années 90
entre 1978 et 1991 Jeffrey Dahmer va
droguer violer tuer en allant même
parfois jusqu'à dévorer 17 victimes
et j'utilise la condamner se tuant en
série à 957 ans de prison 30 ans plus
tard la faire passionne avec 197,2
millions de vues en une semaine cette
série phénomène s'impose comme le plus
gros succès Netflix de tous les temps
manger le sandwich mais ce n'est pas
tout sur Internet les effets personnels
du cannibale de Milwaukee se revendent à
prix d'or une lettre de son père à 2500
dollars sa Bible à 5000 dollars mais
surtout sa paire de lunettes
emblématique à 150 000 dollars un
engouement quelque peu morbi qui a
réalisé la douleur des familles des
victimes et notamment de Rita isbel
incarné dans la série au moment du
procès je trouve que Netflix aurait dû
nous demander si cela nous dérangeait ou
ce que nous ressentions ils ne m'ont
rien demandé ils ont juste fait leur
série ce vendredi Netflix diffusait un
nouveau documentaire sur Jeffrey Dahmer
qui pourrait encore susciter de
l'attention envers ce criminel alors les
lunettes du tueur en série jeffreydamer
mis en vente pour 150000 dollars choqué
ou pas choqué
alors je précise déjà que dans la série
tout ce qui dit mot à mot ça a été
reprises transcription de la police à
constamment il va y avoir notamment deux
documentaires sur Netflix de samedi
encore ou cette fois-ci on va entendre
les vrais vrais voix mais toutes les
enregistrements mais pour vous dire les
lunettes donc 150000 euros l'être
manuscrite de son père 2500 euros un
dessin d'école qu'il avait fait petit il
avait fait un petit cœur 1500 euros une
bible qu'il possédait en prison mais
10000 euros voilà vous êtes choqué ou
pas comment tous ces goodies déjà bien
sûr mais pourquoi tu es pas choqué
Benoît là j'avoue je suis je sais pas
mais je vais quand même des fois de mon
parti je sais dire tu sais tu sais lire
les lunettes originales qui devrait
appartenir à l'enquête et aux policiers
mais en revanche d'acheter les
références et les répliques des lunettes
pour se déguiser en lui pour Halloween
non ça me choque pas pendant des années
tout le monde s'est aiguisé en Jacques
l'éventreur qu'avez-vous aussi des
massacres c'est comme ça après moi je
pense pas qu'on se tarifie Jeff Dammer
je pense que on est tous enfin j'ai
encore espoir en l'être humain je pense
qu'on regarde ça parce que on est
curieux et c'est de la même façon
habillé en Asie pour une fête à côté
moi je suis vous choqué oui qu'on fasse
commerce de ça de la mort effectivement
et des familles des victimes en revanche
quand tu dis je c'est normal que ce soit
médiatisé qui deviennent qui soit annulé
non il est pasteur il est pas du lait on
y va parce que c'est de la curiosité
ce sont les tueurs
en série qui reçoit le qui reçoivent de
garçon comme deux filles le plus de
demandes en mariage dans les prisons et
Charles Manson le célèbre tueur en série
qui a fait assassiner Sharon tape la
femme de Polanski et 9 autres personnes
avec elle et bien il reçoit jusqu'à la
fin il a reçu des demandes de mariage
les visiteuses en prison venaient le
voir lui tu ne peux pas savoir le
phénomène ici sur Netflix c'est surtout
c'est toujours
d'accord il y a un côté fascination qui
est presque embêtant moi j'ai regardé la
série Netflix j'ai été j'ai trouvé ça
très très glauque et je peux comprendre
que certaines familles du coup quand ils
voient ça et du mal à faire leur deuil
derrière et en plus je trouve qu'il y a
une tarification de l'horreur c'est à
dire que par là comme tu l'as dit
d'ailleurs on le voit dans la série il y
a des il reçoit des tonnes de lettres
quand après avoir été arrêté en prison
des gens qui disent qu'ils sont fans de
lui et cetera donc ça c'est horrible et
voilà donc moi j'ai trouvé ça très
glauque et c'est pas bon location
moi je suis choqué mais parce que parce
que voilà pareil que ce qui a été dit
fascination morbide qui a payé 150000 €
pour avoir ses lunettes mais il faut que
tu saches quand même que euh
tous les objets dont on parle là
viennent de la même ont la même
provenance c'est un collectionneur
d'objets de saiyalkiller qui a un site
sur lequel vous pouvez aller donc c'est
lui qui vend la Bible les dessins etc et
en fait lui il a récupéré l'ensemble de
ce que j'ai dans un dans des cartons qui
était chez l'ancienne familiale du père
de Damart il a récupéré le dos donc
c'est pas des flics qu'il avait et
cetera et il est vend aujourd'hui
la fascination des Français pour les
tueurs en série du monde entier moi je
suis né par la psychologie humaine quand
je vois un mec comme ça ça me fascine
d'en apprendre de regarder des docs là
dessus
j'aurais pu très bien collectionner des
trucs comme ça
mais parce que je trouve ça hyper
intéressant c'est de l'histoire moi je
prends ça comme de l'histoire alors j'ai
une question des mots que j'ai posé à
Sophie ton fils a 16 ans il a regardé la
série et il pourra pas aller à l'école
quoi il a un t-shirt Jeff gamer
ou pas par exemple quand on joue à des
jeux comme Call of Duty etc et on dit
voilà les jeunes qui jouent trop aux
jeux vidéos à un moment donné ils vont
sortir dans la rue avec canarder tout le
monde c'est faux en fait il y a pas du
tout d'impact sur le cerveau c'est pas
parce que on a une espèce de curiosité
tu dis ça de n'importe où
non pas du tout
j'en ai trois qui sont collées non-stop
aux jeux vidéo donc je me suis renseigné
sur le sujet
Jeff Hammer il sort dans la rue tu t'en
fous et c'est pas la même chose
bah oui moi je suis d'accord avec
Deborah il y a un moment donné il y a un
fonctionnement il y a toujours
d'ailleurs le même en fait et j'adore ce
côté opératoire mais oui le mode
opératoire le côté profiler etc cette
espèce de Messi
j'adore ça ils avaient vous dire un truc
en même temps c'est la première il y a
une partie fascination mais moi aussi
c'est deux sujets différents l'intérêt
pour ça parce que ce sont les faits
divers c'est passionnant et la
scarification qui vient quand même
une différence entre regarder un
documentaire parce que la psychologie
nous fascine est parce qu'on essaie de
comprendre comment est l'être humain et
porter des objets qui lui avoir la scène
et revendiquer qu'en fait on est un peu
d'accord avec lui et qu'on admire très
bien il y a quand même une différence
entre les deux
si on pousse un peu le truc de façon que
ce soit pardon pour Canal mais canal
Netflix et tout depuis 10 ans on fait
des documentaires au moment en avant que
des gens qui sont malhonnêtes je te
rappelle qu'on a fait d'aucun croyable
sur Rocancourt la manipulation de machin
et que même ils vend ses droits
c'est-à-dire que ces gens sortent mais
oui Rocancourt il sort de pris ils vont
ses droits 500 mille balles pour faire
un film
la posture c'est du génie aussi là on
parle d'un imposteur on parle pas d'un
meurtrier quand on parle de quoi c'est
différent pour répondre à votre question
Mathieu juste simplement
posé une question j'aimerais répondre si
c'était pour se déguiser pourquoi pas si
le porte comme ça parce que je trouve
que ça devient d'un coup une idole ou
son héros etc j'essaierai peut-être de
lui
expliquera comme Benoît à côté il avait
10 ans en fait clochette
allez on donne
c'est peut-être plus dangereux du coup
j'aurais peut-être mieux du coup de le
pas bon
c'est comme si vous disiez
mais on se déguise en Cruella on a envie
de déposer sans un dalmatien